I ain't a good start to the podcast oh
it's gonna be a good one is what the
most requested thing for us to do ever
is going on here mmm BAM so it Thanks
done ahh
is it really there was I didn't know
about requests people ask all the time
all right well that's now I'm excited I
really connect this episode of Jezreel
and podcast brought to you by wink I've
told you about Club W before and they
are now called wink that we a I NC it's
a new name a new look and the most
important part it's still the same
amazing wine company right now you go to
try wink that's t ry winc talk on the
flash Jenna Julianne and you can get $20
off right now - so this week is thread
up guys thread up get you up to 90% off
top name brands and designer clothes
like Lululemon Gap j.crew expressed in
and Republic I mean yeah and you can get
yourself an extra 40 percent right now
and go to thread up that's thr edu p.com
slash annejulien and enter promo code
and Julian for an extra 40 percent off
your first order Thank You sponsors
Thank You sponsors was that good one
thank you to everyone that sponsors us
but especially best business men cases I
think I was excited right now fine
people ask me to do this like for a
video all the time yeah for the podcast
too but I literally haven't touched it
like I haven't fiddled with it I haven't
looked at it like I'm excited to finally
sit down and do this because I'm also
genuinely curious so if you just have
this autoplay you have you know the
title we are going to do Pottermore we
are just discovering our Patronus we are
getting up sorting hat for
and we are discovering a warrant I'm
full-blown Pottermore experience right
here on the pocket excited I say we do
our house first then our wands in our
patron o'clock yes I'm good I think one
of us should keep the volume on because
we don't want double okay which your new
year's keep your volume on with our
shadow you did okay
to caricatures no oh not when I said it
all right in the top or DJ have you said
we should do our house first then want
and then patron is less why why that or
because it says this is ordering is that
out oh it is swing this is the order why
would they put the to us on top if you
weren't so slow first I want to know my
Hogwarts house first I feel like I can't
do anything if I don't know my Hogwarts
house that's true you know alright so we
have a shortage of you are hog are
taught by the sword again I can't do it
yet I have to wait for I have to verify
my email or I did that for the first
time I tell you girl oh I just did it
opinion tell you um yeah I'm genuinely
curious for those of you maybe that
aren't like super Harry Potter fans like
me maybe you can just black out and not
know what's going on but for those of
you that are Potterheads like us some
pretty interesting even if you're not a
huge heard about heads first up
hi everyone makes fun of me also for
living in Philly in California and I've
never been to Disney third quarter rules
yeah I've never even been there I've
been to Orlando but I've never been to
the one in California where they have
Harry Potter it's devastating pretty
devastating I really take me yeah we've
tried to like it over time but we never
really successfully fall to through with
the plan
oh when you take me like on date Harry
Potter land
yeah which is going down birthday oh
that's a good plan what are we doing
really yeah or like not but anytime yeah
I will definitely take you I'll take her
anything time also holy [ __ ] we hit 300k
on this channel on YouTube thank you so
much yeah
I'm a badass so I can monitor it really
is so [ __ ] rad especially since we
started the podcast like so whatever and
it's free whatever something like
whatever unless whatever all right you
ready to get sorted by base yes right to
mute your [ __ ] we sorted and discover
your house oh my god what we answer
truthfully
after all the hats decision is final oh
my god wait till this is it like I'm
like scared it because I'm scared I'll
do it I don't like oh [ __ ] okay well
there's no Sun yet for the moon or stars
oh we I have to make my thing fullscreen
right
oh I don't have the same question as you
I have John or dust okay I'm a loser
stars definitely stars - we stop stop
moving on I'm so on question mark dawn
or dusk Donna does a bit well which one
do I like more Josh you don't like
waking up at dawn going watching the
sunset I don't know no actually got done
because you stay up til now probably
dusk oDesk select oh my god
where's your next one say my next one
says what are you most looking forward
to learning at Hogwarts and then I have
all these choices holy [ __ ] I just
picked the choice you pick $3 billion
and this is what kind of instrument most
pleases your ear there's four choices
what are they all in trumpet piano drum
oh man - apparition and dissipation
being able to materialize and Dean earth
- MIDI materialize a will
Transfiguration turning on on difference
of another object lit flying on a
broomstick ah hexes and jinxes all about
magical creatures how to befriend and
care for them but that's definitely is
secrets about the cabbie friend didn't
care for every area of magic I
can warning value but yeah I mean I
think I have to go with nature's right
yeah and I'm going with violin all right
high five Iowa I just saw vial Lambert's
mission off of Julian's hit 2013 album
nightmare fuel AP ep okay my next
question says you can enter an enchanted
garden what would you be most curious to
examine first the silver leaf tree
bearing golden apples on some the fat
red toadstools that appear to be talking
to each other okay the bubbling pool in
the depths of which something luminous
is swirling how am I suppose the statue
of an old wizard with a strangely
twinkling eye
oh my okay I'm gonna have to go at these
red told the children I was in Reno when
your pick is very gentle okay
late at night walking low down the
street you hear a peculiar noise or cry
that you believe to have a magical
source do you proceed with caution
keeping one hand on your concealed one
and one eye out for any disturbances or
draw your wand and try to discover the
source of the noise or draw your one and
stand your ground or withdraw into the
shadows and await developments while
mentally reviewing the most appropriate
defense in offensive spells should
travel with me nuts so where's the
option to call nine-one-one I'm not
going to proceed I'm gonna draw my want
to stay in my ground turn up they're
looking to attack but I'm off me I just
ignore it
yeah I'm like episode 400 of SVU where
he disappear again says gun I was
actually good at though because it was
like this much less predictable than
their other upstairs yeah people were
treating me are you watching episode 400
of se right now and it wasn't at the
moment but we're II watched it was
really a good world yeah wild alright so
many holy [ __ ] get dead
Frank these are their stories
okay because wow this is like been a
collision course of everything that I
like I'm dad okay my next one says if
you were attending Hogwarts which pet
would you choose to take with you oh my
god bring me a more difficult question
okay well Nadia yeah yeah good um sigh a
meze cat ah why I love them ginger cat
Oh black cat white cat whoo tawny owl Oh
screech owl all cute brown owl all snowy
owl Wow barn owls Oh dope common code
Wow matter jack code okay dragon Yoder
uni pictures wirelessly horrible
three-toed tree toads I'm going with a
side Mews cat
I love Siamese cats Wow
you go to the cat out of all that well
they don't have Dobby or Kermit so then
can I tell me it looks like God he is
Bobby has consented don't be with this
sock don't be angry and go okay what are
you most looking forward to learning it
hard oh I had this one an apparition do
separation cool being able to
materialize and dematerialize that well
I like that Transfiguration nope don't
like that I'll [ __ ] with that you don't
[ __ ] it down flying broomstick it's like
you're your own girl outside hey Nellie
jinx that the one you picked with
magical creatures senior it's about the
castle noise dumb who makes secrets
about the castle I don't want to have
any special powers I just prefer you've
got something real [ __ ] yeah which one
are you picking up um I think yeah I'm
gonna be soda bread well we're in
different houses
yeah I wanted to be that long back come
on get the hangar
I'm soaking I love you I'm weighing all
of my Harry Potter fabric great now
afraid oh this is extra fabric and also
the bag that I made for myself it's
really great my god we bought that
fabric that I was like where where ever
you know before yeah we bought it it's
not procurement it was for me yeah it's
not myself an outfit okay all right
I have which or you're right it was for
you yeah which road temps emos mmm I'm
gonna intent it okay the wide sunny
grassy Lane
Oh sounds cleaned okay the narrow dark
lantern lit ally hell no this is the
twisting leaf stream passed through the
woods that sounds lovely the cobbled
street lined with ancient buildings mmm
I'm going with the twisting leaf stream
path through the woods that would be you
yeah I love the woods I belong in the
woods right after year died what would
you most like people to do with a here
name yeah miss you but smile dark I
don't care if people think of me after
I'm dead it's what they think of me
while I'm alive that counts lots of
weird minds that think with admiration
of your achievements or ask for more
stories about your adventures whoo I
like that one
that's me don't worry we'll miss you but
smile not stupid
how did the adventures was okay mine is
how would you like to be known to
history the wise good the great or the
bowl with a bulb hmm I don't know what
do you think the wise is cool the good
is boring do not fix good I don't want
to be the great through the boulder the
world-old
I say wise I would want to be wise or
what I'd be dumb that's a wise decision
if you were attending Hogwarts which pet
would you take okay Julian what do you
want making a song I'm
it alone you already got to make
decision leaves please my guy domicile
there just cats owls and toads tabby cat
Chinese cat definitely not Siamese cat I
already know warming dude hey ginger cat
black cat white cat tawny owl squeak oh
I did a good job
I don't know snowy owl Parnell common
toad toad toad I told you these cats
I was in code daddy cat I'm gonna go to
this work a barn owl nope what well a
white lol okay Harry Potter I'm using
this video because a drink but also I
like this no II know where you may woman
oh cool okay let's roll I've gone
berserk and the headmaster study at hog
one oh my god I'm scared it's about to
smash crush and tear several
irreplaceable items and treasures in
which order would you rescue these
objects from the trolls Club if you
could so that's like which way which I'm
going to pick first
is the one really safer I guess oh it
tells you okay first and nearly
perfected cure for dragon pox the
students records going back a thousand
years finally a mysterious handwritten
book full of strange rooms
sounds like a relatively logical order
okay this is you save the records first
then the handwritten book then the cure
for dragon pox book first dragon pox
records last dragon pox handwritten book
records left okay the only three things
yeah
I think is a perform I think I'm going
to do the student records going back a
thousand years then dragon pox and then
a book so I'm doing team records
thousand years record
sorry no dragon pox been student records
so we just switch the purse - yeah
alright
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this question
mine just says left or right [ __ ] mine
heads or tails I'm going left
I'm a letter B in most sports pithead
it's like when I took the GRE is like
you're not even ready to show to your
score meet ha ha ha ha ha just came home
I knew I was a humble pie oh wow
I'm so excited ok that's exciting I
don't need to be in rhythm doll where
the hufflepuffs I brought the budget
that's what I said the recipe on Twitter
we are watching everybody out there like
what else here I feel like a Hufflepuff
in this combined we're half will puff
we're both here look at turn our laptops
here on prove it
we're both hufflepuff hufflepuff the
baby bubble-bubbles
Hufflepuff owe me money are their paths
alright well that are so exciting ok so
now everyone can stop asking us what our
houses we don't want to wear hufflepuffs
I'm excited we're both coupled plenty to
kind of go
Oh Q your growth returning my profile
yeah the whole page is yellow oh this is
cool well that's cool my Hogwarts house
patrol no one trying to drag laughs ok
discover your world already okay the
wand ceremony
time to take your wand or take your time
take your time and insert abundantly
your answers are final all gods me this
is so much pressure I'm sure we find the
perfect one for you it's very important
that you answer the following questions
honestly first of all would you describe
yourself as
average height short tall I'm advertised
I'm average height and your eyes dark
brown flash black black brown hazel blue
blue grey blue green green grey ha oh
damn mine's blue green red people are
they I don't know what color that is but
it's nice hufflepuff II okay
this is the day on which you were born
an even number or an odd number and what
for our odd is fuck-boy you most pride
yourself on your kindness your optimism
your determination resilience
imagination intelligence originality all
I need help picking order I think you
are originality for sure actually its
original your kindness I think
originality okay
I think I'd be walking the planet but
originality is better okay so go to
resilience yeah that's a good one favor
reasons look I'm resilient traveling
down traveling alone down a deserted
road you reach a crossroads do you
continue left towards the sea ahead
towards the forest or right towards the
castle for it alright alright forest is
the place for me I belong the forest
that's what my parents said the day I
was born
let's throw her in the forest where she
wants to just bring left towards the
favorite we're comfortable very what the
[ __ ] do you most fear friar darkness
isolation small spaces or Heights high
tight tight tight tight tight tight
tight tight tight tight tight to that I
have an airplane on there no I just good
I'm up here of all heights but like an
airplanes pretty high up in the sky and
I don't like it my isolation I'd say
darkness setting darkness darkness is
terrifying
yeah during appreciate of the dark
I'm low-key scared he is high Q low-key
scared of the dark where were we where
we we were like outside and you were
watching something and you're like how
does anyone posted me we're in the woods
or some [ __ ] I only heard that there you
mean yeah but you're scared of the dark
you only get scared let me describe the
setting real quick okay we're outside of
our cabinets like 10 o'clock tonight on
Big Bear and it's like pitch black cold
out with the dogs inside sleeping we go
outside just look at the stars you know
hanging out on the side of the house and
where we're sitting nothing's lit all we
can see is to the left of us because the
moon has lit the lake so never right of
us is just darkness and we're just
talking and we're hanging out with look
at the present all sudden we hear like a
deepest [ __ ] growl you could imagine
like you've never heard a growl and a
bear and it was very very close but it
growled at us and we both want each
other right
holy [ __ ] without a bear and you said
yeah and then we like slowly but frank
like Frank
whatever frantically open your three
chin ran out yeah terrifying
oh I'm like I'm not scared the doclet
please have sort of like woods in our
backyard a little bit like a circle out
there nine hang out like that makes
everything scary I don't mind the ocean
is scary and I'm in yeah the ocean man
scary at night [ __ ] up violent and
talk and swim in the ocean at night look
although I have I swam in Atlantic City
that like dirty nasty be too you know in
the ocean at night I wanted to the Santa
Monica beach at night one times really
ocean you look like one of the first
times I came to visit it because I don't
know if you know this but for people
that don't live in Southern California
it's really exciting to be like near an
ocean and like go swim in it so I got
pretty drunk and it's raining down there
bloody hell yeah oh yeah okay right in
the chest and magical artifacts spelled
artifact smell
when would you choose I just felt it
British or paper okay an ornate mirror a
dusty bottle a golden key a silver
dagger
abound scroll glittering jewel or a
black glove chest full of magical
particle charger for sure as not for me
I think I would take on either the
golden key or this bound
scroll because honestly if I'm looking
to the scroll code yeah if I'm looking
through there I would see everything and
then I'd be like I want to know what
this piece of you ever said down scroll
what's yours
wow we got very different whoa cool tell
me appears my okay everybody my wand is
an ash wood with unicorn hair color it's
10 and 3/4 of an inch and brittle
flexibility oh I like mine I have a vine
our IP bond with a dragon heartstring
core wall and a 12 and 1/2 inch and
supple flexibility Wow write that I like
that it's a little bit flexible Wow with
that I like the mines brittle don't
touch me hmm that's cool
I feel like that that's actually they
give you what they give you like your
your how to uniform right
what's that wait why is your thing
really works.i good here play that's all
right no I said we're like what like
Hufflepuff what do we wear yellow yo
which is clearly in yellow Oh Julie have
any Hufflepuff our teachers on thread up
because right now I realize I are sizing
brand like Lululemon Jeff Jeff rest
Banana Republic actually I really love
the Lululemon chef ever wear those all
time lately all the kind and the way you
can get up to 90 percent off these top
10 brands right now is by going to
thread up you go to thread up that's thr
edu P thread up calm slash annejulien
enter promo code Oh Julian again extra
40 percent off your first row on top of
the good deals are going to give you
you're getting extra forty percent of
the first are there everything you love
about shopping secondhand the thrill of
finding an unbelievable deal okay yeah
without having to worry about digging
through sizes of things that they won't
accommodate you later or they're very
expensive you can shop on trend like new
fashion from top name brands and
designers for up to ninety percent off
retail online it's read up search by
your favorite brands and you can filter
by size color price and style set up
triple inspects each item by hand to
ensure that all their clothes are like
new and a lots of them still even have
the tags on so kind of dark on slash an
undulating plain 40% off your first
order also guys make sure you try wink
wink as I've told you about was
previously Club W and they make it very
easily very easy sorry to get wine
personalized to your palate and
delivered right to your front door so
they renamed themselves from club W to
wink that's winc a new name a new look
but the same wine company that you
always knew it's awesome right now
they're offering you $20 off and you go
to try wink that's try winc comm
question on Julian and if you've never
used a service like this it's very cool
because they find a way to very simply
get your palate of what kind of wine you
like they they give you a sort of a
little palette quiz and when you answer
that quiz they now have on hand what
wines would work for you and what
wouldn't and so they're going to send
you a surprise so if you look like and
it's really great there's nothing like
as cool as having a box of wine shipped
to your house like you're not having a
leave for it's very very cool so right
now you get $20 off and complimentary
shipping when you go to try wink that's
try winc complex Jenna Julian thank you
sponsors are you sponsor you know
Israel I thought I'm wearing a yellow
hat and I realize that I'm a Hufflepuff
hi yellow hair right here helpful
powerful puffs um when we get married
submit you I just wear helpful puff
outfit sure when you read all right we
already are made so how are we going to
wear how the puffy gay don't worry don't
you remember
yeah all right are we doing our petronas
what's the matter with you why you
smiling like that
what brain what the door open it's like
here other people who may not know what
I tell me it's all like Harry's is like
a stag or something I a deer or what do
you call it I know it's like his charm
that like protects them you mean so this
one has noise I don't know it does it
yeah oh yeah see that Harry
well the Patronus is a kind of positive
force a projection of the very things
that the mentor feeds upon Oh happiness
and the desire to survive Remus Lupin
reimage the juniper tree makes is my
father
this is like a beautiful little
experience it's called the yeah Patronus
I'll discover your patron what is it
killer I know but that's all right
you know stop [ __ ] going through the
forest without me oh okay wait insuring
wait wait winner for cool yeah well
that's all it says right now is you pick
shine glitter or glow well why did you
pick one you pick anything it just okay
shine glitter glow glitter
I guess it takes for me if you find I'm
going to put
blade leaf blade or four leaf blade or
thorn I hope I get something differently
this is close well you have to do it we
are salt salt you have to do it faster
of it okay I am [ __ ] no it take twice
for me oh I'm sorry
reiden dream discovered dance which
one's your and cover [ __ ] my plague
brown green what is cream playing play
play play
let's hear that right or shadow right oh
hell yeah oh whoa oh that I saw
something you nearly produced a Patronus
your clothes I'm close guys think feel
says hmm I appear free or safer ooh six
eight so free free free I'm free I'm
free your Patronus is almost here huh
well you're getting close to
Comfort advised and press comfort
comfort advised and press comfort
comfort on the first Turkish [ __ ] me is
why what we are going talk [ __ ] thanks
okay who I'm by the lake oh my god
so click drag and release for your
Patronus likes wipers little comfort
advise and press oh my god oh my god
stop don't fit you guys my Patronus is a
wet tile interior comfort and safety
guys there's a little white dog wet see
are you kidding me
all yours is cool is it applause hi mine
oh I like it it looks pretty cool it's
like an honor what I mean it's like
shaped like an owner Wow cute turning
around so you can see it oh my gun stop
I cannot I can't right now look at life
is long and weary Patronus are you
committing radar that's great are you
[ __ ] kidding me
can you imagine commenter's like sucking
my face off is like come save me wet B
and then apparently I won the corner
no he just runs out to the Dementors
he's like and I'm like yeah hell yeah
dog save me because every question is
like safety comfort like nothing events
or nothing battling oh man wow this it's
like this website [ __ ] knows me dog
this is cool this is really cool that
was really fun Ryan Martin it really
does like from the side were playing an
auto right with the big tail yeah he's
really cute
I'm sorry what we did it we're powerful
platypi we're hassel puffs and I cannot
get over the fact that my Patronus is a
dog yeah
pretty great it's [ __ ] lit I want to
know what your guys's are or like what
are the other possibilities of things
that you could get one of how many there
are also if there's more things to do on
fire more that were not because I know
popular I'm so excited right now I feel
like a full person like I can go to Mary
Potter world now and be like I'm good
cuz you know how you are if I feel
caught in acid because if I know my
Patronus part of your identity
for real whoa okay can you have like a
whale as a butcher
why not a picture for your dolphin can
you imagine if no I want like a really
slow manatee to be my Patronus look I
got a camera hmm how well do you know
your Hogwarts staff and subjects get
that that that that that that that that
that's better now expecto patronum are
you reading about your patronum yeah
well does it tell you about your
specific one hmm
now I want to go yeah yes yeah yes sir
what you have to what you have to find
yours or something and then go to
details about it because who yours if
you want to turn it see now it just
takes you back to that page so you can
like lookee here
here you turn this and then guide it
pine marten
let's share it I just cover my services
up I'm on the Jay King rallies at
Pottermore something wow this is doubt
this is dope well that was fun
we did some Potter more for you guys so
this is uh no longer attend agility
podcasters with Jenna Julian Apple pop
cat
RuPaul Hufflepuff I'm really excited
that are both hufflepuffs because we
love each other
I really want a sad manatee as a patron
ozone pollution thank you guys for
watching magenta Jillian pot turn ahead
oh you better just like when you we're
at the vet earlier today with garlic
butter
Angie and there's like this stupid
looking painting of a cat and so
julius's cat cat me outside how about
that how about cow cat cat me outside
I'll just catch me outside how about cat
come snatch me outside ha snack me
outdoor how about that how about
chilling on Snooki's porch season six of
Jersey Shore that isn't even a season in
my mind I'm erasing it from a memory
reality we recently re-watched all of
Jersey Shore and the last season is
really the whole series for you yeah so
like double season up to season five I
mean yeah it's been shitty at some
points but it's a good show and then
season six is like the expose a of like
how terrible everyone is well they were
all like making so much money and like
had other shows lined up and I don't
liter might run cleaner able to watch
our me on TV because it's all so [ __ ]
cool and fun and then season six
happening no one cares about anything
they're like you can tell like you were
saying going camping and Shelley Duvall
[ __ ] forest or whatever
Wow my ass pissed I didn't look at my
ass piss don't like it okay welcome to
the house hufflepuff so distracted you
probably know that some of hufflepuffs
most renowned members include Nymphadora
Tonks and Cedric Diggory all
IP such a degree but did you know that
helpful plus house ghosts the fat friar
sounds problematic still resents the
fact that he was never made a cardinal
or that Hufflepuff has produced the fuse
dark wizards of any house in Hogwarts
hey he's going to sit over here and do
some helpful potpourri research and
we'll see you guys there you don't know
the time I even have let us know what
house you guys are and what your bond
looks like and all that good stuff you
guys being here we'll see you guys next
week hopefully all of you have a
wonderful Valentine's Day and die a
wonderful week Hufflepuff with that
better
hufflepuff or TT and so let's hop out
follow me outside how about that later
guys bye